Azeb Wolde-Giorghis.
- Ce document confirme
ce que beaucoup redoutaient,
le renversement de
l'arrêt Roe contre Wade.
Chaque État serait dorénavant
libre d'interdire le droit
à l'avortement. Lns
ne se sont pas fait attendre.
"Ils ne vont pas s'en
sortir comme ça, dit-elle,
on est plus nombreux qu'eux
et on va se battre."
- Toute la journée,
les manifestants ont défilé
devant la Cour suprême, où
les deux Amérique nt.
- Abortion is violence!
- Le document de 98 pages(-
ramènerait les États-Unis
n arrière.
Le très conservateur
juge Samuel Alito écrit :
Les neuf juges de la Cour
suprême devaient trancher sur
la question à la fin du mois
de juin ou début juillet.
(slogan)
La fuite publiée
par le site Politico a eu
l'effet d'une bombe. La grande
question : qui en est l'auteur?
ête est en cours.
"Quel que soit le responsable,
dit-il, il doit être poursuivi
et aller en prison pendant
longtemps, car il a ébranlé
l'indépendance même
de la Cour suprême."
Le document est authentique
confirme, le chef de la Cour
suprême, mais pas
"Cela touche à touche à touches
les décisions liées à la vie
privée, qui vous mariez, dit-il.
En Floride, ils peuvent
passer une loi interdisant
le mariage gai."
"Je suire,
lance la sénatrice démocrate
Elizabeth Warren, la Cour
suprême est en train d'imposer
ses points de vue extrémistesets
qui vont payer le prix",
ajoute-t-elle.
Pour beaucoup il y a
une profe dee dee dee dee dee de
culture aux États-Unis.
"Les droits de 100 millionsde ,
et les Américains doivent
se faire entendre lors
des élections de mi-mandat,
en novembre."
Avec cette fuite,
la Cour suprême vient de
perdre un peu de son lustre.
Ici Azeb Wolde-Giorghis,
Radio-Canada, W